Hey yeah ya know I'm so glad you could
come over come on how you doing
oh yeah well I am
you look great by the way I can't serve
this really sweet you had an important
question asking I'm so sorry I just I
meant to call you last night
it's about today's team yeah um for the
last Jedi no you know like could you get
one or is it more than one because I
need it in order to figure out what
we're doing on the train today I'll see
about today floral I'll tell you that
Olaf is in frozen - he's it more than
one Jedi is it ominous Josh it sounds
ominous
they something happens to you and Mark
for just mark are you a Jedi answer my
damn question me Josh I'm so sorry I
didn't need to raise my voice this ain't
no wife anyway um so I don't know if you
had a chance to look yet but Ken Branagh
the director of our movie will you know
he wrote some sides for today that he
wanted us to go over so I thought maybe
we could just go click oh so I start off
I say on who do you think is the
murderer on the orient express.the train
that we're on right now I not know man
this is you you say I don't know but
you're not asking about questions when I
say what would what would you have me
ask Daisy or your whatever your
character's name is and then you say
sila right salmon uh-huh am i a Jedi
right it's been paralyzed from the waist
down and then you release these you
answer honestly and then Ken is going to
have the camera on you and you can
practice that now answered all my
questions
all Ken's questions formally days you
don't do this
Josh launching any of your stylist
questions
no no Daisy you're not you're answering
her Star Wars questions you being tested
for leader Julian is Snoke Palpatine
on the last Jedi
what's the deal with Raider
why don't you want some again question
you
hey youtubers is Charlie I can't believe
she said no to dame judi dench how can
you say no to her so what I'm going to
do is my top 5 craziest Snoke theories
talking about star wars series is so
much fun it's even better when they're
wildly outlandish so I just wanted to do
a fun bonus video for Star Wars Fridays
so there's a new round of the Star Wars
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's for IMAX gift
certificates be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything so I'm going to start with the
less crazy ones and work my way down to
the most crazy Snoke Theory there are a
bunch of them but I just tried to pick
out five of my favorites so number 5
Snoke is the last Jedi not Luke
Skywalker or Rey like everybody thinks
the two most plausible theories is that
the last Jedi title refers to either the
combination of Ray and Luke they are the
last of the Jedi as in plural or it's
simply referring to Luke the last Jedi
because the opening crawl in Episode
seven names him as the last of the Jedi
but the reason this is my number 5 is
because there is an element to truth to
it like all great theories have a kernel
of truth no matter how outlandish they
found but the idea that Snoke descends
from an order of Jedi that he is trying
to create a new order of Jedi with kylo
Ren just suggests that he could also be
the last of the Jedi so the only reason
I don't think this is going to pan out
is just because the theory about Luke
and Rey is a lot more plausible so in
the phase of overwhelming evidence for
another theory this is just on the list
of crazy theories but it's not nearly as
nuts as some of the ones that are lower
on my list so number 4 Snoke wants to
possess kylo Ren as in transfer his
consciousness in the way that the
Emperor did during the EU he had all the
clones if you ever read the dark empire
series it's one of the best Dark Horse
Comics Star Wars series ever
during the 90s during the period where
Star Wars was licensing out a lot of its
book content you got the Thrawn Trilogy
there was a lot of great Star Wars
content Luke seeks out the Emperor goes
to this where this is darkside
stronghold while he's there he learns
what happened to the Emperor after
Return of the Jedi this was the greatest
thing for fans to
because you're like oh my god they're
continuing the story what happened after
he threw him down that elevator chef so
the idea was is that the emperor is so
powerful that he cannot be outright
killed he becomes something of a force
ghost himself his spirit transfers into
one of his clone so it's an 18 year old
version of Emperor Palpatine
but the idea stands that sis can
transfer their consciousness into
other's bodies and take them over so
along comes Ben solo this really
powerful Jedi descended from the line of
Vader in an effort to create a more
powerful force user from a fallen light
side Jedi who also wields the dark side
of the force so the theory is pretty
simple that he will build kylo Ren up
and then use him as a vessel to transfer
himself to because his body is failing
so much there are a couple Snoke
theories on this list that depend on his
scars the way his body looks how
decrepit he is how the darkside has
twisted him in how he's going to
continue to survive the reason I think
this won't pan out is because Snoke
himself is supposed to be somewhat
ancient in the galaxy so he's already
long lived he doesn't need another body
but like I said the reason that it's
plausible is because that act is very
common amongst darkside force users
really the only way I think that theory
works is if you feel like the ultimate
boss to be defeated is Snoke and I
really feel like it's going to be a kylo
Ren versus Rey situation it's not going
to be like Darth Vader where he ends up
killing the Emperor at the end something
else will happen it won't be a complete
repeat of Return of the Jedi
number three theory Snoke is Darth
Plagueis slightly more crazy but still
fairly plausible the reason people
thought this initially is just because
he's a bigger boss to be had been
Palpatine and someone who's scarier who
Palpatine tried to learn from the secret
of beating death so he's this really big
figure from the Canon and he's a month
so he resembled what people thought that
Snoke looked like before they actually
saw the movie and even after the movie
came out because he was so big the
hologram a lot of people picked that up
and ran with it and said okay he's just
going to be the movie version of what
the months are even though we've seen
them in Star Wars before but this is
those theories that people like Pablo
Hidalgo Rian Johnson
people behind the cameras have been
trolling bands with just saying you're
Snoke theory sucks so this is typically
what they're referring to when they say
that although there are a lot of Snoke
theories they're just making fun of that
then I'll explain after my number two
because number two is even crazier
number two theory Snoke is really mace
windu I totally love this theory because
it is so crazy samuel l.jackson ears are
burning like he just sits up somewhere
wherever he's sitting in the world right
now listening to everyone talk about him
hell yeah I want to come back to Star
Wars this theory largely depended on him
surviving his encounter with Palpatine
in Episode three in becoming scarred in
the way that Snoke is scarred being
twisted to the dark side of the force in
sort of slinking away to come back and
haunt the galaxy in this physical form
with the first order in kylo Ren the
problem with this and the reason that
the producers like to make fun of fans
so much which is sometimes it's funny
sometimes it's not so funny just because
I think what's really going on with
snoke's identity is that they wanted to
create a brand new characters it wasn't
somebody from the Canon that they didn't
necessarily overly explain early on so a
lot of people were trying to fill the
gaps like if he's such a big figure why
haven't we heard about him before and I
think the simple explanation for that is
that they don't want to reveal too much
information about him they want him to
be mysterious so he is a big figure in
the history of the galaxy but the only
reason you haven't heard about him in
the other expanded materials is because
they haven't written that yet they
haven't edited that in the way that they
added that Death Star MacGuffin during
rogue one like this is the reason for
that glaring error in design in the
Death Star so there going to be some
moments like that in the new film
that'll explain why we haven't seen
Snoke before so even though I love the
amazing Snoke is secretly someone else
theories I don't think they're going to
pan out but my number one craziest
theory which is even more outlandish is
is that Snoke created Rey in a lab like
she's secretly a test-tube baby that was
engineered by Snoke to be this new
vessel so the main reason why that
probably isn't going to pan out you can
already imagine is because he didn't
to immediately know exactly who she was
he just knew there was an awakening in
the force so her parents will be someone
else in there have been a lot of new
theories recently about who her parents
are
like a lot of people think that it might
be Benicio del Toro as an older version
of Ezra Bridger because he's going to be
a villain in the new film and we haven't
seen a whole lot of rebels we don't know
where Ezra is when all these new films
are happening but I might do another
video about that next week I don't think
it's going to pan out either but it's
actually a really good theory so let me
know in the comments what are your
favorite crazy Star Wars Episode eight
theories or they could be for episode
nine just a more outlandish the better
even if you don't think they're going to
pan out just write them below in the
comments what I'm going to do next is is
I'm going to post my Lego Batman Easter
Egg video there's a bunch of new footage
from a Logan that dropped so I'll be
posting updates on the video schedule as
I post new videos but Lego Batman Easter
eggs will post Saturday morning
congratulations to flare Knight you're
the latest Star Wars giveaway winner you
went to IMAX gift certificates please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so there's a new round that
started in this video announce the
winner the next time I post a Star Wars
video while you wait for that you can
click here to learn all about Snoke
backstory that's actually canon to Star
Wars and you can click here to learn
about the new Iron Man suit that we
might see during spider-man homecoming
thank you so much watching everyone but
I thought I'll see you in the next video
maybe me Vinnie Niki me anything
[Music]